So let's dive in to supporting Touch Events,
presuming that you really need to. Touch is supported
across all major mobile browsers and Chrome, Firefox, and
Opera on desktop as well. So touch has its
own set of events, touch start, touch move,
touch end, and touch cancel. These are somewhat analogous
to the Mouse Events. Mouse down, mouse move and
mouse up. Although Mouse Events have only one pointer.
So the target element and coordinates of the Mouse
Event are just on the event object. The Touch Events
are multi touch. So there are three lists of touches
on each touch event object. All the active touches All
the Touches that are affecting the current DOM element
and all the changedTouches. In each of these lists, each
individual Touch is represented by an object that contains a
unique identifier for the Touch, the coordinates of the Touch,
and the target DOM element in the page. Although
this is an important difference. Touch events are always
delivered to the element that first received that Touch.
They don't walk across boundaries like Mouse Events do. So
it's important to hook the right elements. In fact,
it's a good idea to add the touchend handler during
your touchstart handler. And, keep in mind too that
even if you remove a DOM element from your tree,
it still gets the events until the touch ends.